has the commission delivered on its
promises in the past year and what are
its plans going forward
meps quizzed ursula fonda lyon on her
track record at the annual state of the
european union debate
high inflation electricity and energy
price rises
a climate catastrophe
increased food insecurity and a fast
emerging
cost of living crisis
i think our message today will be that
europe
will respond
ukraine's first lady elena zolenska
looked on as president fonder lion vowed
to continue to stand up to russian
aggression as soon as russian troops
crossed the border into ukraine
our response was united
determined and immediate and i think we
can be proud of that
we have brought europe's inner strength
back to the surface
meps welcomed the commission president's
announcement to cap low-cost energy
revenues and share excess profits but
called for even bolder action
the markets the ladies and gentlemen are
obviously speculating against european
solidarity when winter
will really be hard
some meps expressed concern that the
european union was not doing enough
about eu countries that disregard the
rule of law
estado democracy
historical
fragile commonwealth
others called for the eu to remain
ambitious on climate change and lead by
example on the world
public scholars stage autonomy strategic
efficiency
european resource economic
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you